[Music]
in my bad news my bad saluted by Amanda
around Boulos nailed it
here are the five apology languages and
how to find yours Oh like the five love
languages but these are apology
languages so by garry tattoo I need this
oh it seemed guys cool um you know what
though
you know what the Asian apology language
is if you're Asian man get on your
[ __ ] knees or you don't say sorry
that's just a man you just ignore it and
then you try to buy them lunch today are
you doing your apologizing right now to
us yeah oh no no like like this is this
is how it works so so this is this is
not the truth but this is like the
stereotype and the traditional way of
thinking right so like if you're if
you're the older you are and and if
you're if you're a man you have to say
[ __ ] you'll have to say sire to nobody
but then if someone's older than you
then you have to say sorry of that in
what cultures is Asian pretty much most
Asian really most Asian I've made my dad
again like the biggest biggest [ __ ]
fights ever and then we don't talk the
rest of the day maybe even the day after
that and then two days later he's just
like are you hungry and then we would go
eat and then it was like I'm like wait
so do we want to talk about what
happened or anything like that and we
just ignore the whole thing oh that's
great it's like it's like uh not beetle
power but it's almost like um based off
of status and hierarchy it's like the
military even if you're wrong you just
got to obey it so the funny thing is my
grandma my dad used to always get into
it because my grandma had the age on him
in the wisdom and she was actually
smarter and my dad had the man of the
household thing so they were always
[ __ ] bump heads they couldn't figure
out where they were in this [ __ ]
hierarchy you know yeah it's almost like
a pack of dogs always trying to fight
for power and [ __ ] part what's your
apology language what do you do you
don't even know what the five avenues
are but what do you Paul how do you
apologize to Jo and your how do I oppose
sowwy
I learned that Jill Jill needs a hug
first immediately and she doesn't want
to talk about anything and that's it
right yeah I just need affection first
Jenny's affection she needs to know that
you don't give a [ __ ] about words yeah
but for me I've asked to the opposite
like whatever that thing is if she
admits exactly what it is then it makes
me feel better and then I like the hug
afterwards
hi and my man Casey I think I [ __ ] up a
lot by just saying I throw out the I'm
sorry's before even realizing what I'm
sorry for and you're not so that's my
language though I'm sorry no I am sorry
no your language is that you're
defensively sorry and then you're like
I'll figure it out yeah well I'm trying
to figure in real-time as we're speaking
I thought as the words roll out my
tongue I just I'm sorry I'm just I'm
trying to figure it all you think sorry
to get off the hook and defuse yeah
would you it was me other than Marcus
especially the way he said sorry he
should be like I'm sorry I'm like if I'd
say I'm sorry I just get berated with
your way so I'm like oh [ __ ] I throw up
the shield first and then trying to
figure out how to you or do I dunno I
shouldn't even be you know you stand out
in the storm right he did that was like
or is it unclear so you don't know why
you're saying sorry no but no think is
it that the reason I need to figure out
is it's so specific though it I didn't I
need to find like the I need a lineup
all the stars and planets first and then
once I figured that out then I can say
I'm sorry
right right just [ __ ] apologized
already
I'm sorry I feel like Casey messed up in
this episode I felt it that arrows were
going through and I was like I'm gonna
blow the whole relationship yeah dude
you can't do this [ __ ] I'm steve-o you
think I feel bad
whoo Casey look Casey just [ __ ] cut
this that's why I went to Asian history
I knew this was gonna happen just take
all the audio output kpoppers of the
five ecology love language earn five
apology languages here good we need this
[ __ ] it's expressing regret nope
so that's when you simply want your
partner to say I'm sorry both verbally
and with body language that's me and
express regret at what they did without
justifying or making it Jess is yelling
at the camera now that's me that's me
though I like that next one is accept
responsibility so they have these
quizzes on five love languages calm and
so you could take this quiz yourself if
you want click the link in the
description and then if you score as
high like the higher you score in these
certain languages that's your apology
language that you would like your
partner to do to you so accept
responsibility is when your desire it's
your desire to hear the words I was
wrong which is an affirmation that the
person who hurt you does see the pain
they've caused and that's like the
momentary a momentary weakness expressed
by your partner helps you see their
apology as truth so that's accept
responsibility I was wrong he's putting
his ear up to the safe he's trying to
crack it yeah I'm trying now if he needs
to figure out the code I'm working on my
relationship right now come on guys
was wrong this the perfect time oh yeah
you should just stop I'll ask for you
apologize he's so sorry he told us to
tell you oh so she doesn't even know my
own okay there was a member through his
number three position is valid yeah we
both of you take this quiz because we
have issues with finding out our apology
language that's for real we don't know
what the [ __ ] works with the truest
thing I've ever heard on just kidding
news we don't know we have so many
problem genuinely repents you want to
switch seats dude yes get all the hands
over the [ __ ] table this is Asian
it was fate amazing samba [ __ ] you know
what's crazy is what I'm recognizing is
Asians don't have love language they
have sorry language most resound
romantic actually the first two yeah so
alright so genuinely repent is when you
want your partner to not only
acknowledge that they hurt you and are
sorry for doing so but that they wish
they could change or take it back they
also in the same Tim you're saying that
repentance is largely emotional and
shows that the person feels bad and
wants to change that's the key element
the change in behavior thought or action
plastron sounds like the empty promises
one though that's like that I'm gonna
change baby and then you know a couple
months I always don't make promises you
can't keep
yeah after an apology
check it off into a toilet just like
Casey just listen for this on all right
just listen your mouth hurts all the
time
Casey band's understand if you don't say
one word from this point on yeah
honestly he does do all three yeah he
does empty promises he says sorry for no
reason he accepts responsibility because
you don't know what it is that you just
have a matter says sorry how about that
yeah if you don't have any men are in
the comments right now who treats you so
much better than Casey you should take a
look at each and every one of those and
actually think about that submit resume
good kid never yep there's so many
people always in the comments so
precious I can't believe people treat
them that way all right number four is
make restitution so this is all about
making things right this is where we're
gonna make the bed the next day I mean
like covered in flower petals a [ __ ] I
have to do pretty much this is what I
have to do that's kind of Nikki likes
restitution it she likes like what'd he
call it shows of the services active
service that's one of this she likes
that [ __ ] show me that you love me
mm-hmm that affirmation of how things
will get better / how deeply you are
still loved by that person and an action
of healing simply a simple I'm sorry
isn't going to fix anything it's all
about the sincerity behind those words
and the action taken so that is best
aligned with the person's love language
like everything these are complicated
that's we have them sound the same so
the last one is requesting forgiveness
so if this is your apology language that
means that you are all about hearing the
words do you forgive me so to you it's
important that your partner really
expresses love in the form of wanting to
be forgiven and start again which one is
the one where you feel good when they
stab themselves I mean I like the one
when they're like I'm so sorry
and like they cut the hand off I think
that's shared pain I think that's like
when you steal in India
that's not an apology thing at all you
guys got to see what I gotta study this
cuz they sound pretty much the same
right they sound exactly like where's
you you know the apology [ __ ] thing
behind you that's restitution service
yeah oh I see okay service right okay
that was mine absolutely so you would
make you have the same lovely absolutely
that's all I wanted my trans at my
currencies will drop when you recognize
it and you you want to do better and you
are trying to do better
that's not change alone which I never do
that uh genuinely repent no that's not
okay that's my favorite for you when
they wish they could change or take back
the action oh yeah that is a change in
behavior I think that's the truest form
my favorite thing is trying to milk it
cuz if she's really sorry I need three
more blow jobs right leverage you know
I'm saying for awhile and I can be like
I just don't know if I'm over again so
you wait so that you get more below I
can't wait for her to make a snake I
can't wait does she make them say I'm
not very often that's why I got a room
do you make you should make up problems
where you know she's gonna trip on and
go see you left the garbage can open
booby trap yes garbage can open what's
up girl I thought you promised me I'm
like hey Nikki you [ __ ] up drink this
whole bottle of water first cuz you care
about I wanted right now
damn dude this is good stuff I need to
learn how to say sorry in general
cuz I'm always [ __ ] right just should
take this quiz and she should tell you
what her apology languages and then
that's how you know how to come at her
when you [ __ ] up oh that's true you mean
when she [ __ ] up know that that's when
you would take the quiz find out what
your apology languages and then she
could know how to come to you and she
felt that that right there is everything
that's wrong in a relationship
even though when she [ __ ] he's like uh
you're talking about with she [ __ ]
outbreak cuz I daddy don't [ __ ] oh you
got me right here
[Laughter]
[Music]